all right good morning
we've got some folks online and we've
got lots of folks in the room how's
breakfast
yeah
it works I'm just see if my Gizmo wakes
up this morning it's still early
there you are hello
uh my name is Richard Campbell this is a
talk I've done a few times although it
keeps evolving on me I sat down with it
the past couple of days to say what
would I say now
you know I started writing the first
version of this in in 2019 we were all
so happy and carefree
so it's been a crazy few years but uh I
I come from British Columbia
that's my house on the left my
neighbor's place on the right we call
this the animal Highway
and uh this is a Wednesday morning and
Wednesday morning in my town is garbage
day
and so I didn't know until I put the
camera in but I he have bears come and
visit every week to see if I put out my
garbage early there they don't mess
around now look I've been I'm in
Minnesota this is not that impressive
dude you should see the Australians they
go nuts for this they got all the
poisonous spiders and snakes and stuff
but you show them a bear they go crazy
but it's Minnesota you get these in the
city right they're around but yeah
notice he's standing right at the front
of he's literally surveying his domain
right now it's like who put up the
garbage
anyway I make a lot of podcasts any.net
rocks listeners oh wow okay thank you uh
and Carl's here too he's doing his
Blazer Workshop so he's working way
harder than I am uh Carl started Donna
rocks back in 2002 which predates the
word podcast by like three years uh I
came on board in 2005 on show 100 and I
think we're at 18 15 now so got a few
and a few years ago I started running as
radio because I felt like the sicid Min
audience wasn't being well represented
and so every Wednesday since April of
2007 I've put out a run ass so we're at
about 850 of these uh free to download
you can get them on any of your favorite
they're on Spotify and all your favorite
players uh we interview smart folks from
the industry right
and uh for a few years I made we made a
show called the tablet show and this
this brief period around 2011 we weren't
sure if.net rocked uh it was a scary
time for all of us uh but by 2014 it's
like okay Don that's fine and we rolled
all that back together again and uh this
Talk's really built on all of the
stories that I've collected being a
podcaster talking to really smart people
lots and lots of them and but I will
reflect on Niels Bohr who said
prediction is difficult especially about
the future not that I know what else you
would predict uh
and that's the guy who came up with the
atomic model like his PhD thesis is the
idea that like the proton in the center
of the atom with the electrons around
that's neospor that's his stuff
so which is all pretty recent that's
like the 20 the 1910s like only 100
years ago that we've really got in the
atomic model look at the mess we've made
uh as because I you can't talk about the
future of software without talking a bit
about its Hardware as well and we're
definitely pressing against some
interesting limits when it comes to
hardware and that's going to be
reflected in our software over the next
few years
we know the cloud is a big deal right if
we talk about the previous decade like
what's really happened the previous
decade but we all got into the mood of
using somebody else's computer by the
minute on demand
uh so that's kind of table Stakes today
you've got to have a cloud strategy even
if that cloud strategy is no Cloud
please it's still a strategy also
smartphones for better or worse the
phone has penetrated human civilization
it's about four billion of them in use
today that's pretty much one for every
adult human we just tipped eight billion
humans like this week congratulations
good news is that it only took us 12
years to get from seven to eight and
that rate it does seem to be declining
so it's going to be a while before we
get to nine
but you know new markets
and the combination of cloud technology
smartphones and various other bits and
pieces have been we've got an awful lot
of data some people call it Big Data
it's just a lot of data I'm not saying
it's good data
but we've got a lot to munge through for
better or worse and these are just trend
lines and they're easy ones more compute
more devices more data
that's pretty obvious there's not a
really hard things in any of that
obviously that's going to happen for the
next few years but what's actually going
to change in this next 10-year period
one aspect is the end of Moore's Law so
our friend Gordon Moore the reason we're
all here ultimately uh the guy one of
the guys who helped form Intel he made
this observation in 1965. so a really
really long time ago that for us for the
same amount of money in a piece of
substrate in a piece of silicon he could
put twice as many transistors in
every two years that's basically what he
said they didn't didn't call it a law
because it's not a law right gravity is
a law doesn't matter whether you agree
with it or not it's there the only way
we get this doubling effect is a lot of
people work really hard
the good news is it's worked out pretty
well this is data pulled right from
Wikipedia it's just a a an exponential
graph on the left side starting with the
4004 processor in 1970 up until today
the number of transistors has kept
growing at an exponential rate we're at
tens of billions now now if without that
exponent that exponent on the left side
the graph is kind of stupid right it
because the numbers are irrelevant until
you get to the last numbers are so huge
but not everybody's a numbers person
it's not an easy way to look at it so a
better way to look at it this is the way
I describe it I show you one of these
what's this
warp drive from the Enterprise nope
that's this
is a cray 2 supercomputer Circa 1985.
this was the most powerful computer in
the world at the time only a few hundred
of them are ever built there are about
16 million dollars in 1985 dollars
uh they were cooled with mineral oil
because they ran so hot they were
constantly pumping mineral oil on them
to keep them from melting down it's
curved to keep the wires as short as
possible the speed of light mattered
inside of that supercomputer and it had
1.9 gigaflops of processing power you
would do 1.9 billion floating Point
operations per second they modeled
nuclear explosions with this it was
these were in universities and
governments they were these incredibly
powerful machines now compare that to an
iPad 2.
so now we fast forward a few years 26
years later in 2011 Apple releases the
iPad 2 it's 600 bucks keep it away from
liquid
battery's pretty small 1.9 gigaflops and
you play Candy Crush on it
you hand it to children to keep them
quiet and it works
but that's really the application of
Moore's Law right that 26 years later
the computing power of the fastest Super
King in the world is a device we give to
children
and that's not fast hey that's 2011
that's now 11 years ago if you talk
about a consumer compute device a
maximum performance consumer computer
device look at a video card look at it
the the GTX 4090 if you can find one
so that's about 1600 bucks retail if the
eBay scammers aren't marking them up
although I guess we're out of Bitcoin so
this is it's getting easier to find one
of these
um 16
000 cores in it
82 teraflops so that's 40
000 times faster than that iPad 2.
and that's a commercial product retail
product you can buy this at a Best Buy
right and by the way this thing's 450
Watts by itself
so if you're going to put one in your
computer make sure you got a big power
supply because you still have a CPU and
if you're really a nut buy two because
you can Crossfire them and connect them
together I don't know why you would but
you could
top of the line compute devices today
anywhere in the world are the new
generation supercomputers the current
leader is an American computer it's a
race between the Chinese the Japanese
and the US to build the fastest
supercomputers and at the moment in Oak
Ridge Labs down in Tennessee the
frontier supercuter is the current
leader it's uh a hundred Eleven Hundred
petaflops so 1.1 hexaflops
for 600 million dollars
it takes 20 megawatts of electricity so
bring your own nuclear reactor
and takes up about 8 000 square feet so
not exactly for the home but that's um
14 000 times faster than that
40 90 or 600 million times faster than
the iPad 2. welcome to Moore's Law
and yet it's ending
we can't keep going on this curve I
could just can't skate that straight
line forever why well the way the way
that we increase Computing performance
is by putting more and more circuitry in
more and more transistors in the same
die we stopped making processors faster
a while ago we kind of topped out around
the four gigahertz range after that
stuff just starts to melt
and so we put more and more process
together that's what that super computer
is really about it's hundreds of
thousands of course that all work
together on these crazy problems
in in 1970 when the first processes were
made they were using a 10 micrometer
process you could almost see the
transistors
today we're talking about five nanometer
and a nanometer is just one of those
crazy numbers right it's too small to
conceive of we have electron tunneling
microscopes that allow us to see down to
the individual transistors five
nanometers across
but a nanometer is another one of those
it's a billionth of a meter well a I'm
in America you don't know what a meter
is anyway right
meters like this
roughly three feet
so if you're going to cut that into a
billion pieces those are really small
right and one of the ways I try and
describe this is I use seconds
if I ask you to wait for a million
seconds how long am I asking you to wait
for it's about 11 days it's a long time
if I ask you to wait for a billion
seconds that's 32 years
so
you know one second is to a nanosecond
as one meter is to a nanometer you know
you compare that to 32 years to a second
it's a crazy small amount and at five
nanometers you start to care about the
width of atoms so this is from the IBM's
scuttling tunnel scanning tunneling
microscopy they're actually taking a
picture of the substrate the yellow
bumps you're looking at are silicon
atoms
silicon atoms are 111 picometers across
roughly 0.1 nanometers those blue holes
those are phosphorus atoms that's the
doping for p-type substrate when you're
making a microprocessor
40 atoms across at 50 nanometers we're
running out of atoms like you just can't
get a lot smaller before Quantum effects
and electron tunneling and so forth to
take over so we're getting to the end of
Moore's Law now is that a terrible thing
no not really it changes stuff if you
can count on the fact that you're going
to have more compute every 18 to 24
months you're disincented to do other
things like improve architectures
and that's why Intel still makes
essentially the x86 chipset right the
instructions that were put into the 80
86 back in the 1980s still there
is all about compatibility and so this
layers of architecture they've stacked
on top of their processors over the in
the intervening decades have built up a
lot of Croft it's actually a lot of
shuffling around instead of a modern
Intel processor to be as fast as it is
now compare that to the arm architecture
because it started later because it
could count on 32-bit wide buses and 64
buses they've simplified the
architecture and so you're consume a lot
less energy for the same work processing
workload in modern architectures
and largely we're insulated from that as
as software developers we don't really
care about the hardware anymore for the
most part we just write our code and it
runs on all these platforms that's magic
it's also inefficiency because we can
afford it
being attainability is more important
than raw performance all the time
when you look at the current Leading
Edge chip in my mind is Apple's M2
that's five nanometer process it's about
20 billion transistors in that package
and that's an eight core CPU a 10 core
GPU a 16 core neural net tuned processor
and a whole bunch of cash
they've integrated all into one chip and
if you've played with the latest
generation Apple machines they're some
of the finest computers made today
they don't need to be much smaller than
five nanometer I don't know how much
we're going to get from it but the fact
that that's running out means that our
work is going to change a little we're
not going to count on having a lot more
compute everywhere it's just going to
spread out and the nice thing about the
future is that it's already here it's
just not evenly distributed
there's lots of places where you're not
running five nanometer gear and so forth
and so over the years that's going to
propagate this stuff's only going to get
cheaper I know if you've looked at the
latest Max but there are many things and
cheap is not one of them
on the next layer talk a little bit
about networking everybody really
excited about 5G
you know when I started doing this talk
about in 2019 5G was in the news it was
very heavily hyped and now it's here and
nobody cares like anything that works
it's just not that important when it
works it's like air if you've got it
it's great if you don't have it you're
pretty unhappy
connectivity is the same thing
I mean 5G was kind of raced out into the
market by the telcos because they needed
a competing product they needed to show
they were getting faster the problem is
that wireless has physics problems
if you want to get more data per cycle
wirelessly you have to go up in
frequency
so the our old 2G cell phones back in
the day were 450 and 900 megahertz and
then our 3G phones got up to about two
gigahertz most 4G was 2 gigahertz 5G is
22 gigahertz you can pack a lot more
data at those high frequencies they just
lose penetrating power when we were at
900 megahertz you could take a phone
call in your basement and expect it to
just work could move a lot of data but
it was reliable we had enough problem
with 2G with two gigahertz moving up a
bit doesn't penetrate near as well
22 gigahertz has problem with things
like leaves
windows
I did a 10 I did I had a speed test set
up on my 5G phone and I was literally
outside facing a 5G Tower and I'm
getting epically fast speeds like just
racing along
and then I turn around turns out I can
block 22 gigahertz
so part of the challenge of the 5G
network is they need a lot more cell
notes closer together because the range
is limited the penetration is limited
and cell nodes get saturated and so
we're not seeing the full potential of
5G yet
but the power consumption is pretty low
the devices are pretty Compact and so
more and more we have it being able to
put these chipsets into almost anything
the biggest thing that 5G gives us more
than anything is making 4G really cheap
you're starting to see this if you buy a
new car today that most cars just have a
cell network built into them you may not
have access to it but the car is sending
Telemetry back to the factory by default
the lower the 3G and 4G stuff is so
cheap the car company just includes it
satellite network is real starlink has
happened and we got one I mean I'm in
the part of the world where you might
actually try this I've got one at my
cabin on the coast in British Columbia
at this point
Elon is the largest satellite operator
in the world there are 3 100
operational starlink satellites all the
other satellites in operation around the
planet is about 1700.
so yeah dude's got a lot of satellites
they're all the same they're not very
interesting they're in a series of tiers
but the bottom line is you can take out
this pizza box size dish set it up point
it at the sky it'll adjust itself
internet
decent internet too about 20
milliseconds of latency and depending on
where you are 100 to 200 up and 100 to
400 down
like a cable modem it's not as good as
what as fiber but it's pretty good for
not needing any wires at all
and the Next Generation stuff he's
talking about will work directly with
cell phones
all he's got to do is stop working on
Twitter and maybe we get some of this
stuff done
yeah but let's speak to what these
things combined really mean
lots of it
cheap connectivity and lots of it
networks almost anywhere this is this
idea of ubiquitous Computing that we
just have compute everywhere it's going
to affect us as Developers
these days the little chips that end up
in things like dishwashers and so forth
they can run.net
they've got into the esp32 is 10 bucks
if you buy it in quantity it's less than
a dollar
so why would you put anything else in an
appliance and so
it's a it's a reality that we can expect
i p addresses in every Appliance
I'm not going to say if that's good or
bad I'm just saying that's the path
we're on it means that for us as
developers there's a tremendous a number
of places to do work in do I want an IP
address in my toothbrush no
yeah but am I going to get it probably
that's the cheapest compute
all right one other scene Setter before
we start digging into specific
Technologies got to talk a little bit
about the pandemic I mean we're getting
down there now it's it turns out it's
not just going to end it's gonna fade
away it's getting less and less
interesting we still have people getting
sick and dying I mean that's the truth
we did this great Cloud migration our
friend Sacha told us that you know in
April my March and April of 2020
in two months two years of cloud
migration happened as we pushed
everybody to work from home and a whole
bunch of companies have said there's no
way you can work for a home said hey
you're going to work from home
uh now that's not a big deal for us if
you're a developer you may have been
working from home long before that it's
a lot of productivity around that I
can't wait to write the history of zoom
and how that evolved you know because we
clearly went this through distinct
phases there there was the your muted
phase then there was the turn off your
filter you're not a cat phase
uh and then there was the turn off your
camera nobody needs to see that phase
although there was also between that
everybody show your pet phase
and oh everybody show your kid phase
that's the fun part about the pandemic
but now we're getting into the really
hard part which is the economic impacts
now we could say is this the pandemic is
this inflation I don't even go into that
that's not the important part the
important part is that companies are
uncomfortable and when they're
uncomfortable they get stingy they spend
less money right it's caution they're
not sure what to do now this hasn't
happened for quite a while I have the
Good Fortune to have been in Computing
for more than 40 years and so I've gone
through a few downturns and it's not
like technology stops when the economics
get a little tougher it's that it gets
focused we start caring a lot about
return on investment and we haven't had
to do that for a long time we've spent
year decades now in kind of a growth
build whatever you want do experiments
let's try the new thing artificial
intelligence is a good idea a crazy
mindset
when we get into a downturn pace or an
uncertain phase we start thinking about
the important parts of software and in
my experience software can really only
do two things it can increase the
efficiency of an organization so fewer
people can do more
or can measure that organization more
precisely so that you can find
Opportunities to make more
anything else is kind of moot
so if you're nervous and seeing the
layoffs that's going around in the big
tech companies right now is pretty
nerve-wracking right if this is true
that that Elon actually laid off half of
Twitter's developers by Stack ranking
them by the number of lines of code they
wrote
that's going to make Harvard Business
review of one of the dumbest things you
could possibly do I don't know if it's
actually true but as companies get
nervous and they try and find ways to
cut back
the people they're going to look to are
the ones that don't seem to provide
value to the company
how does your company make money
because we're often removed from that as
developers we rarely directly make money
for the company typically we build tools
that help others make money
or reduce the cost of operations
if you pay attention to that and you
make sure that that's the stuff you're
working on you're very very valuable to
an organization including in the
downturn times
so it's worth your time to focus a
little on how does my company function
what's important to it and how do I
contribute to that because we can help
companies get through rough times by
helping them be more efficient but if
we're not working on those problems
we're not helping the company and we're
not helping ourselves
okay let's talk about technology
the browser continues to be the winner
for better or worse when it comes to
building especially in-house software we
tend to use the browser that does not
seem to be changing there's a few good
reasons for this it's not JavaScript
right what's the good news about a
browser
all the machines already have one
nothing to install nothing to upgrade it
pretty much handles its own upgrade
process anybody who opens up any of your
web apps immediately gets the latest
version so all that versioning stuff
goes out the window by default it tends
to restore stuff only on servers good
practices natural security model
National perimeter you don't have to
deal with a lot of that it's almost
worthwhile working in web development
the good news is also that we've built
some pretty good Frameworks and we
continue to build more the rates slowing
down thank goodness but you know you
probably work with one of these if
you're a web developer because they're
efficient they're a rapid way to build
the kind of code your organization needs
internally this is going to continue it
is the most productive way to build
internal apps in some external stuff as
well we've got the progressive web app
which is really just a set of rules for
how we make regular users not understand
they're using a web page
right give them an icon now they're
happy right a little bit of a manifest
that's all you need that was a bunch of
other cool stuff going under the bwa
things like queuing and and disconnected
Behavior not that anybody really does a
lot with that it's so much easier just
to always be connected than it is to try
and figure out how to make a
disconnected client that works
and if you've been playing with the
latest stuff you know that our friend
Steve Sanderson and he hates when I do
this a few years ago it was actually
2016.
took this web assembly standard found a
weird version of Open Source c-sharp and
made C sharp one in a browser and blue
Microsoft's mind as well as our own but
it took a few years for Microsoft to
take it seriously but today we know it
is Blazer and my friend Carl is teaching
a class on it this week and it's C sharp
in the browser but webassembly is
nothing specific to Microsoft web it's
at least part of the browsers that's why
there's go
and several other languages that you can
now work in the browser so the browser
is increasing its ability to serve a
variety of developers that you can
program whatever language you want
effectively webassembly is simply saying
the place where JavaScript lives is a
set of hooks put what you want in there
we're still at the beginning of this
what we're going to see with webassembly
in the next few years is going to be
impressive in our ability to build more
software whether you want to go down the
Blazer path or not we're going to see
more options around all of that
I will take a few minutes here to make
fun of web 3 because it's easy
at the moment
uh
there's a couple of bits of it that
makes sense and none of them involve
nfts okay the decentralization mindset
is a logical swing away from web 2. web
one was the server under your desk right
in the 90s in the early.com boom we ran
our own hardware for the most to our
part then we found out that was really
hard
and expensive to do well and so web2
said ah we're running on Facebook that's
a good idea
and I give up control entirely live in
other people's walled Gardens and now
we're pushing back against that again to
say hey maybe we should have a bit more
control about where our stuff runs that
doesn't mean it's going to run in the
cloud
and we don't necessarily own the cloud
but that's a little bit more of a
neutral ground than a site that
literally makes its money by selling you
as the product I think we're kind of
done with that I don't have a big
problem with blockchain blockchain is an
interesting technology it only applies
to certain cases it's not the default
for anything but its ability to create a
public record of transactions is useful
and so for certain applications that
makes sense I look at it as the same
relationship that BitTorrent had to
Napster Napster was effectively a
criminalized organization it was hurting
a group of companies none of us minded
hurting the music industry
but a tainted BitTorrent which was
actually a very cool technology just
associated with stealing music and
blockchain has the pro same problem it
is associated with crypto
and if you have X you know FTX uh
crypto right now you're a bit sad
because that's a lot of value that just
disappeared
but don't blame the technology blame
what people did with it we're still
feeling around for what this stuff
actually is
and those two main bits this idea of
choking passing and creating a public
record and being more decentralized
their emotions that will continue but
it's never a simple path and so we're
seeing mistakes being made along the way
some more intentional than others
dot Net's having a good day we just
shipped.net seven we say we I didn't
ship anything uh I got to be part of dot
net comp that's fun but that's just me
being a dancing head right uh but some
really really smart people working in
Microsoft work really hard for a long
time to push out features every year
uh it's going to continue for the
foreseeable
future.net 7 is a very performant
version of.net I hope you're having some
fun with it it's not the long-term
support version so many companies hold
back on these non-lts versions they're
going to stay on six if they've even
moved off of 4.8
lots of people still living happily in
4.8 because you know what web forms
works and it ain't common
right like it's really not coming
so how do you move off of any of that if
you're going to at all like does it make
sense and that software functions so
it's hard to get away from it
Microsoft's working really hard to try
and give us a unified client native
experience in Maui now this is a recur I
talk about web first because it's
dominating for a reason
but it's not trivial to make a web
client that looks great on phone tablet
and PC either
right it's actually pretty hard and
trying to do that and natively is also
very challenging Microsoft's got an
interesting set of bits together on this
it's definitely V1
and our experience has been that they
don't get it right till V2
although they'll probably call it
version or V3 although they'll probably
call it version two because they'll make
a 1.1 just to confuse us because numbers
are hard
but we're still in early days of this
and if you've been listening to Dr rocks
you know I've done a lot of shows around
these different client Stacks trying to
feel around for why why are we trying to
find a big native experience and for the
most part it's because we're being asked
to make more apps that work on whatever
device the user has that's the real
problem with these multi-client apps the
customer doesn't care they don't care
that it works on a phone and a tablet
and a PC they care that it works on
their device
whatever that may be and we could write
it three times but we never get paid
enough to do it so we try and write it
once and that's really still too
difficult to do
but I would also point out another
approach to the multi-client technology
is the Power Platform
and now this is not normally a tech that
you bring to a set of Developers
right they pre they present this as the
no code low code solution so a couple of
things I look at is someone who gets to
sort of observe the landscape all the
time there's about 20 different no code
Loco products out there Power Platform
is only one of them oracle's got one
Salesforce has got one like they're
everywhere to me that says somebody's
feeling around in this area and lots of
people are trying to figure out is there
a set of tooling out there that allow us
to build the heterogeneous client so
uh phone tablet PC working against the
cloud
for typical data over forms problems
yes right that's absolutely in action
here's the interesting part with the web
power platforms approaches again we've
talked about this a little bit on the
show is that
the tooling helps a I hate the term
citizen developer it's terrible
how about domain expert
right and I'm going to go back to my 90s
roots in the VB era right where real
developers programmed in C plus and
crashed Windows routinely
and then a group of folks found Visual
Basic and they found I can build a
Windows app that doesn't crash windows
in the process
but they were typically not developers
right they were domain experts there was
somebody just trying to do their job
better and they found this tool maybe
they found access maybe they found a VB
and they played around with it and they
ruined their career because as soon as
some as soon as the boss figured out
that you could write VB to do that
automation that's all you were going to
be doing from then on
For Better or Worse right and we grew a
new generation developers from that
well I see that same movement happening
with these tools the domain experts can
sit down and build some automations
generate a set of forms that work across
different platforms fairly easily the
smart bit is we as the so-called Pro
developers and I'm not a big fan of that
term either can create more tools for
them so if you want to customize the
client experience to fit more with your
organization you can do that and then
hand back to the domain experts to
actually build up the UI and the back
end that's they still need help with
that the you could jump through a lot of
hoops trying to drag and drop your way
through a logic app where if you can
write me a decent API that I can call
into my power app you can save me a lot
of pain and possibly organization a lot
of pain too
Microsoft started to call this Fusion
development
right the Ikea that there's a group of
no code folks that are knocking out they
they have that domain expertise to knock
out the baselines on these apps and then
we're adding in the bits that need to be
there what you are seeing the latest
round of Tools around this now is that
it does fit into an existing CI CD
pipeline that it can be tested that the
code can be properly checked and
deployed and rolled back like real
software because it is real software
none of us were getting to the bottom of
our to-do list anyway and this is often
stuff we didn't want to do in the first
place it's bloody hard you're trying all
these different tools to get there so if
somebody's willing to take some of this
off your plate and you can build the
back end pieces and the other bits to
make it work well help give them some
guide rails to build stuff we can
actually maintain it's not a bad outcome
I'm not saying the answer is clear yet
these are all new bits but the next few
years this is not going to get smaller
it's going to get bigger and it can help
broader Strokes containerization we're
still seeing this evolve I look at
containerization as just the next
evolution of virtualization
virtualization goes back decades the
first versions of virtualization I play
with were largely for testing for
disparate Hardware
and then they became actual production
environments to help us consolidate data
centers and now we have containerization
which is virtualization with the
operating system stripped out now we
have to just have a manifest for all
that we get that cattle versus pets
mindset where we're just re you don't
fix a machine you just modify the
Manifest and build another one and
iterate quickly uh we're really seeing
good Tooling in the containeration space
for brown tape modernizing Brownfield
apps for being able to wrap them up into
packages I've been reading a good series
coming from some of the Microsoft blogs
on taking old IIs apps and putting them
into containers
because they need to be protected and
need to be broken down into better
discrete units than the way they are
right now they don't you don't want them
sort of just sprawled across a virtual
machine so how do I get the virtual
machine out of these old apps containers
seem to be working in that direction I
think we're going to see containing
containerization push down more and more
into the operating system level where
individual apps are essentially going to
be a virtual instance could be run
anywhere you don't really know and you
don't care
that you can put that it might be a
piece of virtual desktop might be a
piece of a virtualized app you don't it
doesn't matter you'll be able to do that
just keeping apps away from each other
because they behave badly
but also recognizing we don't get to
rewrite everything so let's put the
things that are still important but not
really writable in small enough boxes
that they can't hurt anybody
so we're going to see more of that if
this is feeling a little overwhelming
that's okay
uh
we're in an industry that changes very
rapidly but we don't have to we get to
choose you know I've been doing this
long enough for now I am not that
excited about the new bits I'm not
racing I have to try every new thing
every time anymore
because there's more than one way to
have a career and in fact your mode of
career is going to evolve as you age and
change
you can grab the new bits every time if
you want you ready to jump on the new
stack I'm going to talk about a bunch of
new Stacks coming up
that's great
but we also value experts in an existing
stack because those stocks don't go away
the pool gets smaller but the number of
people also shrinks
ask a Cobalt developer how busy they are
right now
because the Cobalt stuff didn't go away
but the training sure did and now I'm
eating late 60s early 70s making more
money than they've ever made in their
lives really would like to retire but
aren't going to give up the cash
and so it continues this could be asp.ed
web forms
you know that Tech's been around a long
time a lot of code is being written and
it's not all going away and so there may
not be as many web forms Developers
but there's still a need for them and so
you're in an interesting little space I
would say
it doesn't mean you stop learning do you
address the Modern Problems
right how do I make web forms work well
on a phone
but how do you address that problem
space right like and be aware of that
where that is and if it you know hit a
point be the one that knows okay this is
the point where you're against the edges
of web forms and you should really think
about how we migrate that to something
else
or keep it maintained it's also a good
career there's a bunch of ways to do
this just pick the things that matter
the most to you work hard at being the
expert on them and you'll be the
important man you know you'll be the
bigger fish in a smaller pond it's still
a good gig
or
be the be in the new Pond where
everybody's a small fish and we're all
racing around trying to figure things
out
there's one way to have a great career
you know you can try you can experiment
you can live in different spots
okay let's talk about artificial
intelligence
and I show Hal for a very good reason
artificial intelligence is an extremely
old very abused term it comes from the
1950s Marvin Minsky Dartmouth University
he was trying to raise money from the
military building automation he
succeeded but that's the first time the
term artificial intelligence used we
don't hear it until how until 1968 2001
A Space Odyssey that's the first time
the general public heard the phrase
artificial intelligence and then it
tried to kill everybody
setting up our relationship with
artificial intelligence right that's
just how it's always worked Terminator
it's all the same thing over and over
again right the tropes make us weird
about this here's the way I talk about
artificial intelligence AI is the term
you use for technology that doesn't work
the moment it does work it gets a new
name it becomes Predictive Analytics or
Vision systems right there's all of them
as long as it doesn't work it's AI
when it does work it'll be peeled off
and this is actually a very clever
graphic because the shortest lines the
planning scheduling optimization that's
the tech that Minsky worked on in the
50s for the U.S military
expert systems came in the 1970s the
original speech recognition systems of
the late 80s and 90s those are the ones
you had to train over and over and over
again then we got into better natural
lasting processing and then you get
these latest lines in about around 2011
2012. we had a new generation of neural
Nets up here that's when stuff like Siri
turned up
where now you didn't have to train for
speech it just worked right it was a
machine learning model trained on a huge
amount of voice so that it could
recognize anybody's voices except
Australians
and I say that you know it's kind of a
joke not actually a joke
that was the one area didn't work all
that well on and you can incorporate
these various Technologies Machine
Vision and so forth into your software
so if you've got a reason to recognize
objects you can do it it's my favorite
recognition system of all time because
it is absolutely correct
right the software did what it was asked
to do it looked at the picture and found
all the instances of dog
and this is an interesting idea and I've
seen customers starting to do this where
they're now the big thing with a
smartphone or even a tablet is you're
taking the device to the work as long as
we were living in the PC land you always
brought the work to the device right it
was strapped to a desk and so you know
everything came into your inbox and then
you processed it and it went out and
outbox but as soon as you get into those
small form factors now they're going to
the work and suddenly things like
cameras and recognition becomes a big
deal
and we've got soft for this you don't
have to be a Leading Edge developer to
do this today you spend a little time in
cognitive Services the image recognition
systems are pretty darn powerful and
they can tell you this one dog is three
dogs
uh same with the chat bot thing I'm not
a huge fan of chatbots nobody is but
again if we're doing more with less
first line tech support as a set of bots
is this is not that difficult to build
the natural language processing stuff is
solved you basically have to build up a
large enough glossary of information to
answer appropriate questions but it's
very cost effective to be able to deal
with a lot of the dumb questions that
come in rather than involving people in
them and so they hit a point where they
have to be escalated there that's
efficient work and it's modern AI For
Better or Worse more on the edge of
what's happening right now Microsoft's
been playing with this thing called the
form recognizer so this is a vision
implementation system to recognize forms
fields and then actually turn them into
forms fields so being able to scan a
paper form and just have it fill it in
in a digital form
my thought on this is so why can't I
just point this at a
web app and have it turn it into a
modern app because it's just forms on a
screen just like the paper what's the
difference so this seems very obvious to
me that this is an automation path to
modernizing software and to modernizing
workflows where we get rid of the
physical forms we go more digital all
the way and be able to switch over
quickly
for when Young Folks ask me about how
what areas to get into and Computing the
biggest opportunity space I tend to talk
about data analytics because it's still
well behind we've had Predictive
Analytics for decades it was just very
expensive and complicated you had to do
a lot of planning to build up Predictive
Analytics systems but that's just not
true anymore part of that is cloud
that we simply today we have enough
compute that all these different
predicted analytic models like
clustering incentive analysis and
Elliott waves and so forth instead of
having to figure out with math which one
you should run just run them all
it's just Cloud compute it'll cost you a
few dollars against a given data set and
then you look at the results that make
the most sense so we've got good
automation around that and you throw in
machine learning on top of that it has
machine learning models that know your
data better that have learned against it
to be doing even better Predictive
Analytics today the sexy is called
prescriptive analytics so this is
cycling through Predictive Analytics
with actions so now we build up a set of
actions so you've probably experienced
this whether you knew it or not
lately I found if I throw a bunch of
stuff into a shopping cart and then
close the page I get an email from them
sometime later about hey you know you
threw some stuff in the cart there uh
how about a 10 discount
all these Tickler emails
there's no person involved in any of
that now this is the Predictive
Analytics model where they're trying to
predict if I send you this particular
does it get more results in this Tickler
right and this set of stages you
gradually build up a tree but this is
all yield stuff this is how our software
makes the company more money
right that we increase the retention of
of customers that we get them to buy
more and we get them into other products
and so as you but you can't guess you
can't figure this out for yourself what
you got to do is let the data do the
thinking right the machine learning
models try all these different things
look at the result and then turn tune
the overall model it's not easy stuff to
do yet but you're seeing a lot of places
of course I've only talked about
e-commerce you're starting to see these
kinds of prescriptive analytics being
used for things like Harbor maintenance
when do we take a gas turbine down for
repair it's not necessarily when it's
worn out but when it's going to be the
least used or we have enough backup that
it could be down for a few weeks so we
might change out parts that may have
another six months on them just for
because we don't want to wait till it's
too late
um I saw a bunch of this prescriptive
work done around the California
wildfires where they're trying to figure
out is it you kill a certain number of
people when you evacuate them
so can you evacuate them earlier at
lower stress so you're less likely to
cause heart attacks and things even
though it's more disruptive it's
ultimately less costly
so they're starting to use machine
learning models against that kind of
data save lives
it's an area that needs more explanation
we have more data than ever before but
we know less and less about it and it's
because we only have so much time but
the tools are getting smart enough and
inexpensive enough to really be used a
lot of this machine learning models
their cloud services you can run for a
few dollars for a week and then shut off
if it doesn't do anything for you
on the development side we've got the
open AI guys and if you want to build
another version of asteroids you can
you just write out descriptive texts of
what you expect the game to do and it
writes the code for you that's fun and
and amusing but the far more relevant
one is co-pilot if you spend a little
time with copilot you'll learn pretty
quickly yeah I don't have a write a lot
of this code but I do have to write very
clear instructions for what I want to
have happen so this is just an amplifier
for us it's another tool it's a way to
find code quickly right that's sort of
like a super stack Overflow in a lot of
respects
where this is getting crazier now if you
haven't had a chance play with this
stuff you get you know now it's 10 bucks
a month it was free for quite a while
but you can do a trial uh it takes time
to be expressive enough with co-pilot to
actually get useful results out of it
but for a lot of plumbing and routine
code it's pretty good it just needs an
operator right this isn't replacing
anybody this is just speeding up your
rate of experimentation
now it's not like they're holding still
on this yet they just announced that
co-pilot for Power Platform
so now we're having domain experts going
to start describing what they want to
have happen and then they've now just
announced hey GitHub because as if we
didn't have enough stuff to talk to now
you can talk to copilot because it turns
out writing out those descriptions too
much work just talk so this is in
preview
so you can just try and describe things
again the news will grab on to say
developers are obsolete I have heard
that many many times but when you
recognize the bottom line for a
developer what they really do is take a
business problem and turn it into a
technologically solved problem
somebody has to say the right words
write the right thing test stuff out
evaluate that it's actually providing
value that's us it's always been us
it's just another tool for doing it
faster
other new technology what's going to
replace the smartphone because the
smartphone's kind of done
you know it's been a slab of black glass
since like 2007.
you know before the iPhone came along
phones were kind of fun they had pop out
keyboards and little attachments and
like they were cool now they're all
slabs of black glass they're bigger
they're smaller they're longer they're
taller higher resolution lower
resolution One camera two camera three
cameras what five cameras
they're all kind of the same
but what they've really done is
completely penetrated civilization
everybody's got one so it's ripe
for an evolution we're kind of stale and
you can see the industry feeling around
for this the obvious candidate to
replace the smartphone is the glasses
the goggles the visor some kind of
augmented reality this is a mock-up of
what people think Apple's going to
announce someday soon there is no
evidence that this is true so I show it
to you as a lie if you want real ones
there are real ones this is qualcomm's
xr1 so it's a pair of glasses Tethered
to an Android phone it's about a
thousand bucks
cameras facing outwards writing data
directly into your eyes microphones and
earphones if you like to Glow more the
Google Glass look you can go with uh
toshiba's Dyna Edge more the industrial
style or there's hololens Microsoft's
wildly overdue to make another Holo lens
Alex kipman's now left the company so
it's going to be a while but hololens
was an extraordinary device it still is
it's still for sale it's still 3 500
which is not the expensive part the
expensive part of of companies running
hololenses at scale it's about a
thousand dollars per month per device in
Cloud costs
now for certain verticals this makes
perfect sense right if you're
maintaining high-end Industrial
Equipment the fact that the AR device
can basically make the unit transparent
to you can have your checklist live you
can actually see that you finished a
maintenance step physically and check it
off for you that you can request an
expert who can now go in their hololens
from a different location and look
through your glasses at what you're
working on and give you advice this is
pretty profound work
four certain verticals so you talk about
Pratt and Whitney does which builds jet
turbines for for airliners those are 50
million dollar devices and then they do
a five million dollar maintenance cycle
on it the fact that they use a bunch of
thirty five hundred dollar thousand
dollar a month headsets makes perfect
sense because the glasses allow them to
show a detailed record of exactly the
maintenance being done what parts are
replaced that those parts were authentic
like all of the problems they had that
they have addressed with this device
and the hololens is now several years
old it's a fully contained computer
strapped to your head
it's right to be modernized there's
several talks behind from Moore's Law
perspective it can have denser chips it
can have better batteries it can be
lighter and smaller and faster a lot
bigger field of view there's lots of
possibilities there this is an area
that's about to take off it reminds me
of the Blackberry in like the 1990s
so a company called Rim made this
Smartphone in the 90s the Blackberry had
a keyboard on it and you could hit email
on your phone
let me say that again email on your
phone
in the 90s okay now we all have email on
our phone and we wish you didn't but
back then it was a big deal now to pull
that off hey you had to own black bears
they're about a thousand bucks a crack
in the 90s but you also had to run a
huge back-end service you need a
customized version of Microsoft exchange
with all the Blackberry Enterprise
extensions need a couple of guys in
white lab coats to keep the thing alive
but your Executives got email on their
phones they called them crack berries
because everybody was crazy about them
right they were expensive they were
complicated to maintain they tended to
be for ex for senior people in large
organizations much the way that we look
at AR devices today the hololenses for
specific verticals for specific
applications
the path from the Blackberry to the
iPhone is a reduction in cost and a
diversification of its technology we're
a ways away from that yet but it's
absolutely apparent we're on that path
when that comes along that's a gold rush
for us talk about a crazy time that's a
whole new class of ifart apps we haven't
written yet
more importantly the phone fundamentally
is still the same interface that we're
used to right
screen keyboard mouse
screen touch
kind of the same
now being a 3D space
that's a different interface it's going
to be hard to do that well what
information is well represented that way
what work is better served that way
that's the things we're going to
struggle with but the ones that get it
right are going to do very very well and
that's just the next few years that's
imminent
let's talk about meta
because they're trying with the
metaverse it isn't going well
now part of that is recognizing a year
ago our friend Mark Zuck was smart
enough to recognize that Facebook was
already doomed right this we're all the
product their actual customers are
advertisers that was already dying so
it's not that he had a divine
inspiration to try and make the multi
the the metaverse real it's that if he
didn't do this he was dying anyway and
the consequence of a Year's worth of
effort is reducing the value of Facebook
by 650 billion dollars
I know the FTX guy lost 16 billion
dollars but 650 billion dollars
that's a hell of a case study
and now what they're going to lay off 11
000 people
they are trying to find the 3D internet
effectively right now we had second life
20 years ago but we're trying to find
the workspace on it the problem is you
don't get to start with social media
nobody wants this and I actually think
it's held back the evolution of the
metaverse primarily because people don't
want to be associated with Facebook
now we I do know there are companies
that are looking in the Enterprise space
for what's better represented with these
goggles what kind of workloads make
sense
the headsets that meta makes are pretty
good the Quest 2 is easily the best VR
headset out there it's self-contained
it's a few hundred dollars they've just
announced the quest Pro which is fifteen
hundred dollars so I don't know how many
of those you're gonna sell but Microsoft
also jumped on board with teams for the
Horizon workspace so collaboration in 3D
you know without legs
that's one of the things nobody needs to
see your legs if you want to get into
the space you can today the most popular
programming environment for all the AR
stuff Unity C sharp
it's not the only one you can go work in
the Unreal Engine if you'd rather live
in C plus but if you think this stuff's
cool and you're looking at the
opportunities and you want to think
about what business can do in the space
spend a little time with some Unity
we're training it's not that difficult
and it is interesting and spend a lot of
time in a VR a set of VR goggles to play
with the AR goggles they're all there
all right we got only a few minutes left
let's go to the higher yeah the fun
stuff let's talk a little bit about
Quantum Computing because people ask all
the time now Quantum Computing is a
super Computing problem so you know I
talked about the frontier super computer
what do they do with that machine
mostly they're problems like weather
prediction and and fit and fluid Dynamic
modeling if you want to build a high
efficiency airliner when you use the
supercomputer and if you want to
accurately predict hurricanes to use a
super computer and quantum computers are
a particular class of supercomputer
they're the kind that doesn't work
uh they're trying to solve it's a very
difficult problem to actually make these
things work getting quantum entanglement
means typically cooling things with
liquid helium so you need to build a
room for your quantum computer that has
that stores both liquid nitrogen and
liquid helium because you have to use
the nitrogen to cool down the device
enough to be able to put liquid helium
into it liquid helium is only liquidated
a couple of degrees temperature range
then it turns back to a gas it makes
things explode so you need venting
systems to manage when you screw up
because you're gonna
uh they're not easy things to own now
we've had some breakthroughs uh a couple
of years ago the Sycamore processor by
Google uh with 54 qubits they only use
53 for the run because one of them was
broken uh managed to do a particular
problem uh solve a particular problem
they thought would take 10 000 years for
conventional computer to solve it was
eventually determined they could figure
it out in two and a half days IBM proved
that but they did in 200 seconds so okay
an achievement
uh the Chinese with a photonic quantum
computer with 113 qubits did a Bose
unsampling analysis that we already knew
the answer to but it was the kind of
compute problem if you were going to do
it in traditional computers would take
billions of years so pretty clearly a
success in improving Quantum views that
was 2020. and now IBM with their evil
processor in 2021 using transplant
architecture they've now been able to
they've been running some trials they're
up to 120 qubits which is pretty good we
think the action gets interesting in the
few hundred qubits the 300 400 we start
to get meaningful results this is very
difficult compute problems and really
the question is we've only done sample
problems that aren't that interesting
what are the real problems that matter
what could we do with a quantity
computer that anybody cares about and
it's not breaking encryption breaking
Christian actually takes a very very
powerful quantum computer long before we
will be able to do that we'll have NE
will have other users quantum computers
but more importantly
quantum computers are only good at
breaking encryption that's based on
primes is this they're good at primes
there are encryption strategies that
don't use primes we're already starting
to switch them
on the threat that that could eventually
be destroyed so don't worry about the
hype around the whole ending of
encryption thing there are solutions
we're working towards them but this
actually solves some real problems my
current favorite problem is a quantum
chemistry problem
it involves agriculture
now we know in modern in ancient
agriculture we had to rotate crops right
you would grow if you kept trying to
grow wheat on the same land year after
year season after season you run you
deplete the soil now today we have
industrial fertilizers we use the Haber
Bosch process developed around World War
one because it also makes explosives to
for refertilize the land but before we
had fertile industrial fertilizers this
is one percent of the world's energy
consumption is used to make fertilizers
to make food but before that we used to
rotate crops and we the crop we
typically rotate in was a bean because
on that Bean on its roots was a rhizome
and that rhizome is a symbiotic bacteria
that actually affixes nitrogen it has an
enzyme inside it called nitrogenase
we've studied this thing for 200 years
we roughly know how it works that this
enzyme is able to grab
water from oxygen from water and
nitrogen from the atmosphere and make it
into ammonia in the root of The Bean so
you grow beans for a season then you
pick the beans then you plow the plant
under then you let it sit for a year and
it actually fertilizes the soil and you
can plant wheat again it's not as good
as industrial fertilized but it
definitely works it just takes longer
we know that inside of that enzyme is a
catalytic reaction between iron and
molybdenum that does the affixation of
ammonia we just can't figure out how it
works because it's a compute problem
that has two to the 170th complexity
they're only two to 150th atoms on Earth
so this is a problem outside the scope
of classical Computing but a quantum
computer should be able to knock it out
in about three or four minutes
now if they solved it we would then know
what the catalytic interaction is it
doesn't mean we know how to reproduce it
just that we know what to look for and
that's enough that typically now it
becomes an engineering problem of can
you reproduce this and if you could what
would it mean for civilization
we stop making industrial fertilizers I
can imagine a little Spike with a watch
battery or a little solar panel on it
that you put beside the plant that both
measures what's in the soil and then
pulls from the atmosphere the
ingredients that the soil needs to
fertilize it plant by plant no wasted
fertilizers no Factor tractor is
spraying them
it's a big change
and that's one quantum chemistry problem
batteries are bad we basically batteries
through Alchemy we just combine
different ingredients and test it we've
gotten better better at testing rapidly
but we don't really know how batteries
work
quantum chemistry problem that we could
solve and make batteries dramatically
better
superconductors you remember you
remember them from the 80s when we got
when we got the red so superconductors
these ceramic superconductors that would
be part of the line like which on the
cube will float we kind of don't really
know how those work either it's a
quantum chemistry problem we spend some
time on the quantum chemistry on this we
could get superconductors up to higher
temperatures where they didn't need to
be cooled at all that changes how we
distribute energy
these are big hard problems and but
they're all deterministic problems like
if once you solve it once you're kind of
done which begs the question like how
many quantum computers are really going
to need we're still looking for
non-deterministic problems that quantum
computers need most of them are
deterministic you kind of get back to
that idea that that Thomas Watsonville
this is a Pocketful quote when he was
the chairman of IBM in the early days
when they were going out to sell their
first Mainframe and he thought maybe
there's a market for five of these and
he came back for orders of 20.
it's hard to understand when your
computer looks like this how many you're
going to need right in those early days
of the mainframes they hadn't made the
transistor yet
the computers were all bespoke each one
of them was different these relayed so
they used vacuum tubes there's a bunch
of different ways to create a bit they
hadn't settled on the Silicon bit yet
that's where quantum computers are right
now each design is different each
machine is bespoke different ways to
make qubits we haven't actually come up
with a stable qubit and when your
computer looks like this you can't
Envision the smartphone you can't even
see it
when Bell Labs made the first transistor
out of geranium this is what it looked
like
you know how do you picture an M2 with
20 billion of those in a five nanometer
process when this is your transistor
they didn't know
one of the guys that worked on that
Chester's guy named William Shockley
apparently not a very pleasant man very
smart and after he built the transistor
he thought it was possible to make
silicon to make them out of silicon and
put them into substrates and he created
a company called Shockley Semiconductor
in an area of Northern California that
would eventually be known as Silicon
Valley
because of shockley's semiconductor
and he actually used mainframe computers
of the day those mechanical computers to
help him model how to build the Silicon
substrates with doping to use phosphorus
and arsenic to actually shape and which
is why the land in Silicon Valley is
poisoned all that stuff that just dumped
in the ditches
but it began the chain that leads to our
careers
to the microcomputer and ultimately the
quantum computers we don't know what the
perfect qubit is yet but these weird
fragile qubits we're building they might
be enough power enough unstable power to
help us model the reliable qubit so that
we could actually see what the M2 in
Quantum Computing is here's what I know
for sure because it's hard to see the
future when you get this far out and you
just have a tough time imagining those
things
what comes after this is what we choose
to make Moore's Law only happens because
a whole lot of people work really hard
to make it happen
we're the folks who choose we get to
make the future it's up to us I can't
wait to see what we make thank you
[Applause]